Shure: 听过吗啊
Shure: Heard it, right?
Alice:听过
Alice: Yes, I've heard it.
Katrina: 真没听过
Katrina: I really haven't.
Katrina: 听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard it?
Tasha:谁没听过
Tasha: Who hasn't heard it?
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: I haven't.
Shure: 完了哈哈
Shure: Oh no, haha.
Lucia:真没听过哈哈
Lucia: Really haven't, haha.
Alice:好像听过又好像没听过呢
Alice: I feel like I've heard it before, but also not.
Shure: 朴树的
Shure: It's by Pu Shu.
Shure: 这首就比较欢快
Shure: This song is quite cheerful.
Jake:挺好这
Jake: It's pretty good.
Shure: 这是备选一
Shure: This is option one.
Jake:对备选可以
Jake: Yes, it can be an option.
Katrina: 备选二是什么
Katrina: What's option two?
Katrina: 备选二是开心超人
Katrina: Option two is Happy Superman.
Shure: 开心超人
Shure: Happy Superman.
Shure: 大家小时候看过吗
Shure: Did everyone watch it as a kid?
Shure: 完了你这
Shure: Oh no, this...
Shure: 明显跟我们有点代沟啊哈哈
Shure: Clearly, there's a bit of a generation gap here, haha.
Alice:开心往前飞
Alice: Happy, fly forward.
Katrina: 对对对就是这首歌
Katrina: Yes, yes, that's the song.
Jake:然后还有这是个动画片吗
Jake: And is this a cartoon?
Shure: 对动画片
Shure: Yes, it's a cartoon.
Jake:我确实也不知道
Jake: I really don't know it.
Lucia:那行咱俩没代沟哈哈哈
Lucia: Then it's fine, we don't have a generation gap, haha.
Jake:这这这长什么样啊
Jake: What does it look like?
Jake:里边的角色
Jake: The characters inside.
Shure: 就是那个红色的
Shure: It's the red one.
Shure: 那个叫开心超人
Shure: It's called Happy Superman.
Jake:你认识这些这些玩意吗
Jake: Do you know these things?
Lucia:哦我见过
Lucia: Oh, I've seen them.
Jake:完了还是有带差
Jake: Still, there's a gap.
Lucia:但我没但我没看过
Lucia: But I've never watched it.
Lucia:应该我见都没见过我见过
Lucia: I should say, I haven't even seen it, but I have.
Jake:你知道这玩意吗
Jake: Do you know this thing?
Jake:你也不知道
Jake: You don't know either.
Jake:这个人
Jake: This person...
Jake:哦水平还是比我高的
Jake: Oh, still better than me.
Shure: 那还有下一首是这个
Shure: The next song is this one.
Katrina: 你跳舞吗
Katrina: Do you dance?
Katrina: 不会吧
Katrina: Probably not.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one...
Shure: 别猜哈
Shure: Don't guess.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:这确实有点疑惑了
Jake: This is indeed a bit confusing.
Katrina: 有点疑惑了
Katrina: A bit confusing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈好
Katrina: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:我这个虽然没听过但是很好唱的感觉
Jake: I haven't heard this one before, but it feels easy to sing.
Shure: 对很好唱
Shure: Yeah, it's easy to sing.
Katrina: 三选一当开头
Katrina: Let's start with one of the three options.
Katrina: 三选一
Katrina: One of the three.
Shure: 咱们听过最多的就是那个
Shure: The one we've heard the most is that one.
Lucia: 难忘今宵
Lucia: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Katrina: 难忘今宵在最后的我们
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight" is the last one for us.
Jake:开场难忘今宵
Jake: Start with "Unforgettable Tonight."
Katrina: 开开开场要选
Katrina: For the start, we have to choose.
Jake:结束
Jake: Done.
Jake:欢迎大家
Jake: Welcome, everyone.
Lucia: 我投票给雨轩了
Lucia: I voted for Yuxuan.
Lucia:难忘今宵
Lucia: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Lucia:好我一票已经送出去了
Lucia: Okay, I've cast my vote.
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:对对好我是
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I'm...
Jake:我说开场我说开场我说开场开场对
Jake: I'm saying for the start, I'm saying for the start, I'm saying for the start, start, yeah.
Katrina: 但是我们要开头这是开场的
Katrina: But we need to start, this is for the opening.
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:难忘今宵是我来搜索看
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight," I'll search for it.
Katrina: 难忘今宵能用吉他弹吗
Katrina: Can "Unforgettable Tonight" be played on guitar?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:摇滚难忘今宵
Jake: Rock version of "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:可以吗啊要
Jake: Is it okay? Ah, need to...
Katrina: 那你好交给你了
Katrina: Alright, it's up to you then.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:租个琴吧
Lucia: Let's rent a guitar.
Jake:他带过来的
Jake: He brought it.
Katrina: 他有
Katrina: He has one.
Lucia: 哦那可以
Lucia: Oh, that's good.
Shure: 那你怎么再搬回去呢
Shure: So how are you going to move it back?
Shure: 能卖出去吗
Shure: Can you sell it?
Lucia:你是垫钢琴还是垫键盘了啊
Lucia: Are you using the piano or the keyboard?
Lucia:哎那我也可以试试
Lucia: Oh, then I can try too.
Jake:就三个选项吗
Jake: Just three options?
Katrina: 开场的就三选一
Katrina: For the start, just three options.
Katrina: 三选一都已经选不出来了
Katrina: We can't even choose from three options.
Lucia:你说竟然没有琴房
Lucia: You said there's no music room.
Lucia:好可怜啊拍拍
Lucia: So pitiful, pat pat.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:在沙河
Lucia: In Shahe.
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What's that?
Katrina: 公用什么
Katrina: Public what?
Katrina: 就一个公用钢琴
Katrina: Just a public piano.
Alice:沙河那个校区吗
Alice: The Shahe campus?
Lucia:还在沙河
Lucia: Still in Shahe.
Shure: 哎我他妈手机去哪去了
Shure: Hey, where the hell did my phone go?
Lucia:哦这样子
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Katrina: 你自己选
Katrina: 你选呗要不你哪个熟练就选哪个
Katrina: You choose, or pick the one you're most familiar with.
Lucia:我还以为我们学校琴房要付钱
Lucia: I thought our school's piano rooms cost money.
Jake:彩链纸
Jake: Colored paper chains.
Lucia:已经很不可思议了呢
Lucia: It's already quite unbelievable.
Shure: 那就
Shure: Then...
Shure: new boy吧大家感觉听的是听过得最多的
Shure: Let's go with "New Boy", it's the one everyone seems to know best.
Jake:我们不用付钱
Jake: We don't need to pay.
Jake:因为没有
Jake: Because there's none.
Lucia:你说你说嗯你说
Lucia: You say it, you say it, yeah, you say it.
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Katrina: 哪个
Lucia:啊 好吧好吧对对对
Lucia: Ah, alright, alright, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 就来这首new boy好不好
Shure: Let's do this "New Boy", okay?
Katrina: 行牛boy
Katrina: Okay, "New Boy".
Jake:因为没有对
Jake: Because there's none, right.
Lucia:我以为你说在哪不用付钱
Lucia: I thought you meant somewhere that doesn't need to pay.
Jake:没有我以为你说你在说牛boy
Jake: No, I thought you were talking about "New Boy".
Shure: 好 记住了吗
Shure: Okay, remember it?
Tasha:new boy是怎么唱
Tasha: How do you sing "New Boy"?
Alice:没
Alice: Nope.
Lucia:啥
Lucia: What?
Shure: new boy
Shure: "New Boy".
Tasha:哪一首
Tasha: Which one?
Shure: 就是这时的我看见到处是阳光是吧
Shure: It's the one that goes "Now I see sunshine everywhere", right?
Lucia:哪一首
Lucia: Which one?
Alice:哪首
Alice: Which one?
Alice:啊这个听过
Alice: Ah, I've heard this one.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 行那就这个
Katrina: Okay, let's go with this.
Shure: 那就这个了
Shure: Alright, let's do this.
Shure: 大家回去多加练习
Shure: Everyone, go home and practice more.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: Never heard of it.
Alice:是什么这个要开场
Alice: What is it? Is this for the opening?
Tasha:开场对
Tasha: Yes, for the opening.
Shure: 对开场
Shure: Yes, for the opening.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: No worries.
Katrina: 但是我们几个人一起唱
Katrina: But we're all singing together.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 跑调没关系
Katrina: It's okay if we're off-key.
Alice:好 好
Alice: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 也没什么人看
Katrina: Not many people will be watching anyway.
Shure: 说唱也行你就突然来呦
Shure: You can even rap, just suddenly start, yo.
Shure: 就这样也可以
Shure: That's fine too.
Lucia:好你说lou那一段这是艰巨任务
Lucia: Okay, you know that part, it's a tough task.
Lucia:交给你了
Lucia: It's up to you.
Katrina: 然后中
Katrina: And then in the middle.
Katrina: 我们本来定的是两首
Katrina: We originally planned for two songs.
Katrina: 一手开场欢快一点
Katrina: One for the opening that's more cheerful.
Katrina: 一手中间那种配合晚上那种悠闲
Katrina: The other one for the middle, kind of laid-back for the evening.
Katrina: emo一点的那个
Katrina: More emotional, like an emo song.
Katrina: 选的是perfect和唯一二选一
Katrina: We're choosing between "Perfect" and "The Only One".
Katrina: 哎黄老板
Katrina: Hey, Nicous.
Shure: 你这个一定听过了吧
Shure: You've definitely heard this one, right?
Shure: 混欧美圈的啊
Shure: You're into Western music.
Lucia:啊哪个
Lucia: Which one?
Katrina: 黄老板的perfect
Katrina: "Perfect" by Nicous.
Shure: 黄老板的perfect啊
Shure: "Perfect" by Nicous.
Lucia:听过但我这个听的不多
Lucia: I've heard it, but not that much.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Lucia:黄老板听的最多的应该shape of you
Lucia: The one I listen to the most is "Shape of You" by Nicous.
Lucia:哈哈口水干了
Lucia: Haha, my mouth is dry.
Alice:哎呀我妈呀哈哈
Alice: Oh my god, haha.
Lucia:嗯嗯
Lucia: Hmm, hmm.
Katrina: 好像唯一不适合合唱
Katrina: It seems "The Only One" isn't suitable for a group performance.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那我们要不
Shure: So, should we...
Shure: 你给大家solo一个女团舞吧
Shure: How about you do a solo girl group dance for everyone?
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:没有
Alice: No way
Katrina: 我要跳也要拉着你
Katrina: If I'm dancing, I'm dragging you with me.
Jake:你要啊
Jake: You want to?
Tasha:你要不来一段吧
Tasha: How about you give it a try?
Tasha:哈哈哈你好合适啊
Tasha: Hahaha, you would be perfect for it.
Shure: 我不行的
Shure: I can't do it.
Shure: 我害羞
Shure: I'm too shy.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh
Shure: 行
Shure: Fine
Katrina: 那就订perfect
Katrina: Let's just agree on "perfect."
Jake:你跳一个
Jake: You do a dance.
Shure: perfect
Shure: Perfect
Jake:然后以后就是
Jake: And then from now on...
Katrina: 中间一一下
Katrina: Just a little bit in the middle.
Alice:中间的不用合唱吧
Alice: We don't have to do the middle part together, right?
Jake:以后这种计算机视觉的会议啊
Jake: From now on, at computer vision conferences...
Katrina: 可以合唱啊
Katrina: We could do it together.
Jake:就会邀请你
Jake: They'd invite you.
Alice:可以合
Alice: We could do it.
Katrina: 要不然就我俩
Katrina: Or just the two of us.
Katrina: 我俩会笑场
Katrina: We'd end up laughing.
Shure: 我就可以当学术蝗虫了是吧
Shure: So I'd just be an academic locust, right?
Jake:不是就是会邀请你就去演出
Jake: No, they'd invite you to perform.
Jake:当就是你知道那个妮娜
Jake: Like, you know that Nina?
Shure: 妮娜是
Shure: Who's Nina?
Jake:就是信号处里的那个那个女的啊
Jake: The woman in the signal processing department.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这种顶级会议都会邀请他去
Jake: She gets invited to all the top conferences.
Jake:然后这个
Jake: And then...
Shure: 那这样
Shure: So...
Shure: 以后就顶级会议都会邀请我去是吗
Shure: In the future, I'll get invited to top conferences, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:真的没有
Jake: Not really.
Shure: 每每次会给报差旅并且
Shure: Each time, they'll cover travel expenses and...
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 部分劳务
Shure: Part of the work.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:然后这个说是说土灵奖得主请你上台
Jake: And then they say the Turing Award winner invites you on stage.
Jake:哇哇
Jake: Wow, wow
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 所以我手机去哪了
Shure: So where did my phone go?
Jake:所以你要不要跳
Jake: So, do you want to jump?
Alice:要的要的
Alice: Yes, I do
Shure: 我不要我不要
Shure: No, I don't want to
Shure: 哈哈哈你不要给我画这些饼
Shure: Haha, don't promise me things you can't deliver
Lucia:跳跳跳你跳
Lucia: Jump, jump, you jump
Lucia:我站你第二排
Lucia: I'll stand in the second row
Lucia:就是你在我前面
Lucia: Right behind you
Lucia:我站你第二排给你伴舞
Lucia: I'll be your backup dancer
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia:实际上那天徐璐正开始跳
Lucia: Actually, that day Xu Lu started dancing
Katrina: 是我偷偷的从排后面下去了
Katrina: I secretly snuck off from the back row
Katrina: 是吧哈哈
Katrina: Right? Haha
Alice:我们一共准备三首歌吗
Alice: Are we preparing three songs in total?
Shure: 两两首难忘今宵
Shure: Two, two songs, "Unforgettable Tonight"
Katrina: 难忘今宵
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight"
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes
Katrina: 唱吗
Katrina: Singing it?
Shure: 拿音响放吧
Shure: Let's play it on the speaker
Katrina: 拿音响放
Katrina: Play it on the speaker
Katrina: 然后我们就合一合
Katrina: Then we'll just harmonize
Katrina: 难忘今宵你先一边收拾碟子一边
Katrina: You clean up the dishes while we play "Unforgettable Tonight"
Jake:按出来啥了
Jake: What did you press?
Shure: 哦f和弦
Shure: Oh, an F chord
Shure: 行那就这么定了
Shure: Alright, let's settle on that
Shure: 第二首的话
Shure: For the second song
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Jake:这个
Jake: This one
Shure: 不是这个不是
Shure: No, not this one
Shure: 这个perfect大家没听过吧
Shure: Has everyone heard "Perfect"?
Jake:听过
Jake: Yes
Alice:没有
Alice: No
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Jake:唱个太多的新歌
Jake: Too many new songs
Jake:新歌新歌
Jake: New songs, new songs
Jake:不行老歌吧
Jake: Let's go with old songs
Shure: 这个大家听过吧
Shure: Everyone's heard this one, right?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 大家都听过什么比较舒缓一点的歌
Shure: What relaxing songs have you all heard before?
Lucia:第二首竟然要舒缓一点的
Lucia: The second one should be more relaxing.
Shure: 对一人报一首
Shure: Yeah, everyone suggest one.
Alice:想不起来
Alice: I can't think of any.
Shure: 舒缓的
Shure: Something relaxing.
Shure: 我教大家唱我们乐队的原创歌曲吧
Shure: How about I teach everyone an original song from our band?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 哎那耳熟能详一点的那种
Katrina: How about something more familiar?
Jake:草与虫之歌
Jake: "Song of Grass and Bugs"
Katrina: 那种周杰伦的那种弹唱呗
Katrina: Like one of Jay Chou's songs?
Lucia:搞笑
Lucia: Funny.
Lucia:周杰伦的舒缓一些
Lucia: A more relaxing Jay Chou song.
Katrina: 安静然后再叫安静
Katrina: "Silence" and then call it "Silence" again.
Shure: 晴天
Shure: "Sunny Day"
Jake:一谋哥
Jake: "Yi Mo Ge"
Shure: 晴天大家听过吗
Shure: Have you all heard "Sunny Day"?
Katrina: 谁没听过呀
Katrina: Who hasn't heard it?
Shure: 那不行就这个吧
Shure: Okay, let's go with that.
Shure: 我搜一下晴天
Shure: I'll look up "Sunny Day".
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Katrina: 在晚上唱晴天
Katrina: Singing "Sunny Day" at night.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice:那就唱夜曲吧
Alice: Then let's sing "Nocturne".
Tasha:晚上唱夜曲
Tasha: Singing "Nocturne" at night.
Jake:晚上唱夜曲
Jake: Singing "Nocturne" at night.
Alice:晚上唱夜曲
Alice: Singing "Nocturne" at night.
Katrina: 睛天
Katrina: "Sunny Day"
Shure: 好像卡住了
Shure: Looks like it got stuck.
Shure: 啊我知道来吧
Shure: Ah, I got it, let's go.
Shure: OK就是这个样子
Shure: OK, just like that.
Katrina: 你哼一下
Katrina: Hum a bit.
Katrina: 到哪了
Katrina: Where were we?
Katrina: 行那就这首
Katrina: Alright, let's go with this one.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure: 太棒了
Shure: Awesome.
Katrina: 简单
Katrina: Simple.
Katrina: :定了
Shure: 我们定完了
Shure: We've decided.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 到时候收尾就是你钢琴独奏一下
Katrina: At the end, you can do a piano solo.
Tasha:英文歌
Tasha: An English song.
Shure: 新加坡新加坡国语普及率很高
Shure: In Singapore, the Mandarin proficiency is very high.
Lucia:可以可以我支持
Lucia: Sure, sure, I support it.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 再自由组合呗
Katrina: Then we can mix and match freely.
Katrina: 想想
Katrina: Think about it.
Katrina: 想唱的或者想弹的就自由组合呗
Katrina: Think about what you want to sing or play, and then combine freely.
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: That's it.
Katrina: 就是放在晚上的那个环节
Katrina: It's for that evening session.
Katrina: 就是吃完晚饭那个环节
Katrina: It's for the session after dinner.
Katrina: 也可以邀请别人他们一起
Katrina: You can also invite others to join.
Alice:哎嘉宾到晚上几点结束啊
Alice: Hey, what time do the guests leave in the evening?
Katrina: 8点
Katrina: 8 o'clock.
Alice:8点
Alice: 8 o'clock.
Alice:他们吃饭吗
Alice: Will they eat?
Alice:需要吃的吧
Alice: They need food, right?
Katrina: 就是不是说点披萨吗
Katrina: Didn't we say we'd order pizza?
Alice:晚上嗯
Alice: In the evening, yeah.
Jake:傍晚吧对
Jake: In the evening, right.
Tasha:傍晚达美乐
Tasha: Evening, Domino's.
Jake:对对对超级大披萨
Jake: Yes, yes, the super big pizza.
Shure: 秋吧蘸点披萨
Shure: Sure, let's get some pizza.
Shure: 有那个超级大披
Shure: They have that super big pizza.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 你练习吧
Shure: You practice.
Shure: 我觉得你们的讨论
Shure: I think you guys' discussion...
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 已经有有了一个结果
Shure: has already reached a conclusion.
Lucia:好难夹
Lucia: So hard to pick up.
Shure: 嗯那我们
Shure: Okay, so we...
Jake:那我们最后干嘛呢
Jake: So what are we doing in the end?
Jake:最后一天干嘛来着
Jake: What are we doing on the last day?
Jake:先唱这三首歌
Jake: Sing these three songs first.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Shure: 先唱两首
Shure: Sing two songs first.
Shure: 然后最后放难忘今宵
Shure: And then play 'Unforgettable Tonight' at the end.
Shure: 就是散场的时候放难忘今宵
Shure: Play 'Unforgettable Tonight' as the closing song.
Jake:好然后先唱两首歌啊
Jake: Alright, so sing two songs first.
Katrina: 其实如果有自己想唱的就到时候
Katrina: Actually, if anyone wants to sing, they can...
Katrina: 反正连伴奏嘛
Katrina: Anyway, even the accompaniment
Katrina: 连全民k歌伴奏
Katrina: Even the karaoke accompaniment
Jake:对  对
Jake: Yes, yes
Katrina: 然后自己自己练就行
Katrina: And then just practice by yourself
Jake:嗯先唱两首歌
Jake: Hmm, sing a couple of songs first
Jake:然后室友问答是吗
Jake: And then the roommate Q&A, right?
Alice:卡拉自助是呗
Alice: It's karaoke self-service, right?
Katrina: 卡拉自助晚上没有问答
Katrina: Karaoke self-service doesn't have Q&A at night
Katrina: 问答是下午那天定的
Katrina: The Q&A is set for the afternoon
Jake:对那那个内容是
Jake: Yes, the content is
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Katrina: 知识问答
Katrina: Knowledge Q&A
Katrina: 对明天准备一下
Katrina: Yes, prepare for it tomorrow
Shure: 对明天准备一下
Shure: Yes, prepare for it tomorrow
Katrina: QQ给我们出一个
Katrina: QQ will come up with one for us
Lucia:写一下到楼上写一下
Lucia: Write it down, go upstairs and write it down
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Shure: 然后大家记得通知自己的嘉宾
Shure: And everyone remember to inform your guests
Shure: 就是带一点闲置的二手物品
Shure: To bring some unused secondhand items
Shure: 来进行拍卖
Shure: For auction
Shure: 交换好吧
Shure: For exchange, okay?
Katrina: 这个闲置二手物品是交换给谁
Katrina: Who are the unused secondhand items exchanged with?
Katrina: 交换给我们
Katrina: Exchanged with us?
Katrina: 还是他们
Katrina: Or them?
Katrina: 交换就是拍卖吧
Katrina: Exchange means auction, right?
Shure: 就是谁谁都可以来买
Shure: Anyone can come to buy
Shure: 就是比如说好的
Shure: For example, okay
Shure: 我现在拍卖这个
Shure: I'm auctioning this
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this
Shure: 我珍藏多年的酱香型白酒
Shure: My cherished sauce-flavored white liquor
Shure: 嗯自
Shure: From
Shure: 打我爷爷那年
Shure: The year my grandpa
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 对我这是做了一个违背祖宗的决定
Shure: Yes, I'm making a decision against my ancestors' wishes
Shure: 今天把这瓶酒拍卖给大家了
Shure: Today I'm auctioning this bottle of liquor to everyone
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 然后我觉得这瓶酒的起拍价是
Shure: And I think the starting bid for this bottle should be
Alice:两块
Alice: Two bucks
Shure: 两个一钩一钩币
Shure: Two, one Goubian coin
Shure: 好吧我们就叫一钩币
Shure: Okay, let's call it Goubian coin
Jake:好一钩币可以一个coin
Jake: Okay, one hook coin can be one coin.
Tasha:一个coin一钩
Tasha: One coin, one hook.
Jake:很虚拟啊这个
Jake: This is really virtual.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 我们把每个那个小币都上链吧
Shure: Let's put each little coin on the chain.
Shure: 给他哈哈哈
Shure: Give it to him, hahaha.
Shure: 都想说哈哈
Shure: Everyone wants to say, haha.
Lucia:多少数啊
Lucia:可以把它注一下
Lucia: Can we record it?
Shure: 一勾臂
Shure: One hook arm.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:对对对好
Jake: Yes, yes, okay.
Shure: 可以那就这么定了
Shure: Alright, let's settle it like this.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 然后明天商量一下具体的细则
Shure: Then, let's discuss the specific details tomorrow.
Shure: 就是
Shure: That is...
Shure: 复现一下
Shure: Let's replicate it.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We...
Jake:再捋一遍那个时间线啊
Jake: Let's go over the timeline again.
Katrina: 三点啊 2点半到3点是
Katrina: Three o'clock, from 2:30 to 3:00 is...
Alice:嘉宾入场
Alice: Guest arrival.
Katrina: 嘉宾入场
Katrina: Guest arrival.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Yep.
Tasha:呦
Tasha: Yo.
Jake:2点半到3点
Jake: From 2:30 to 3:00.
Jake:对嘉宾入场
Jake: Yes, guest arrival.
Jake:3点开始
Jake: Starts at 3:00.
Jake:赚钱是吧
Jake: Making money, right?
Katrina: 对赚钱
Katrina: Yes, making money.
Katrina: 是自我介绍嘛
Katrina: It's the self-introduction, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 对自我介绍
Shure: Yes, self-introduction.
Jake:班饼开始自我介绍
Jake: Let's start with self-introductions.
Jake:三点开始自我介绍
Jake: At 3:00, start with self-introductions.
Shure: 或者是讲故事
Shure: Or storytelling.
Jake:呃给多少钱呢
Jake: Uh, how much money should we give?
Shure: 看我们心情给
Shure: Depends on our mood.
Shure: 对就是我们作为家
Shure: Yes, we as the hosts...
Jake:就我们作为评委是吧
Jake: So, we're the judges, right?
Jake:评委评委
Jake: Judges, judges.
Jake:我们就坐着小板凳
Jake: We'll just sit on the little stools.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 那一上来就让他们自我介绍嘛
Katrina: Then, let's have them introduce themselves first.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Shure: 我们先表演节目暖场
Shure: Let's start with a performance to warm things up.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 表演什么节目
Katrina: What kind of performance?
Shure: 我们给大家唱一个
Shure: We'll sing a song for everyone.
Shure: 哈哈哈我给大家咬个打火机
Shure: Hahaha, I'll bite a lighter for everyone.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:咬个什么打火机
Alice: Bite what lighter?
Katrina: 他才艺很
Katrina: His talent is very...
Shure: 你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: You don't get the joke?
Shure: 没活就咬打火机吧
Shure: If there's nothing else to do, just bite the lighter.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 你这就是
Shure: You're just...
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 那天说了先干嘛来着
Katrina: What did we say we were going to do first that day?
Katrina: 自我介绍前面还有一个环节
Katrina: There was a segment before the self-introductions.
Katrina: 我看我拍的照片
Katrina: I'll check the photos I took.
Jake:还有一个game
Jake: There was a game.
Jake:game before party
Jake: Game before party.
Katrina: 先知识问答来着好像
Katrina: I think it was a quiz or something.
Shure: game before party是啥来着
Shure: What was the game before the party?
Jake:拼那个拼图吗
Jake: Was it the puzzle?
Shure: 啊啊啊对对对
Shure: Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:那个得拼
Alice: That puzzle has to be done.
Tasha:那个的拼好
Tasha: That puzzle has to be done well.
Lucia:不容易拼好
Lucia: It's not easy to complete.
Jake:哈哈哈很难拼哦
Jake: Hahaha, it's really hard to complete.
Lucia:别打伞或者别的game
Lucia: How about not doing the umbrella game or something else?
Jake:别打伞或者别的game
Jake: How about not doing the umbrella game or something else?
Jake:还有就是藏东西在你们各种各地方
Jake: Also, hide stuff in various places.
Lucia:复活节彩蛋
Lucia: Easter eggs.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 那有点
Shure: That would be a bit...
Shure: 哦藏币是吧
Shure: Oh, it's Tibetan currency, right?
Jake:对藏币
Jake: Yes, Tibetan currency.
Shure: :然后这个拿拿到就归他们
Shure: And once they get it, it belongs to them.
Jake:是藏币
Jake: Yes, it's Tibetan currency.
Shure: 对对对一些散币对
Shure: Yes, yes, some scattered coins.
Shure: 1,000 来
Shure: 1,000, come on.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们我们撒一些币
Shure: Haha, we'll scatter some coins.
Shure: 简称撒币
Shure: Just call it scattering coins.
Lucia:你先挖矿环节
Lucia: You handle the mining part first.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:对对行
Jake: Yes, yes, alright.
Jake:那明天我们撒就撒
Jake: So tomorrow we'll scatter the coins.
Jake:对明天我们当撒撒币
Jake: Yes, tomorrow we'll be scattering coins.
Jake:嗯哈哈
Jake: Mm-hmm, haha.
Jake:明天撒撒币
Jake: Tomorrow we'll scatter coins.
Shure: 明天撒撒币
Shure: Tomorrow we'll scatter coins.
Jake:撒撒币啊
Jake: Scatter coins, yeah.
Jake:我们50个币
Jake: We'll scatter 50 coins.
Jake:我们多少币
Jake: How many coins will we scatter?
Lucia:我们多少币
Lucia: How many coins do we have?
Lucia:150个
Lucia: 150.
Jake:150个币
Jake: 150 coins.
Shure: 150个
Shure: 150.
Jake:撒他
Jake: Spread them.
Shure: 流 流通
Shure: Circulate, circulate.
Tasha: 50个我
Tasha: I have 50.
Jake:不行
Jake: No way.
Jake:哈哈哈有点太多了
Jake: Haha, that's a bit too much.
Shure: 流通有点太多
Shure: Circulating that much is too much.
Lucia:20
Lucia: 20.
Jake:撒他20个币
Jake: Spread 20 coins.
Jake:哦对
Jake: Oh right.
Lucia:光撒的只是一部分OK
Lucia: Spreading is just part of it, OK.
Jake:对撒他20个币
Jake: Yeah, spread 20 coins.
Jake:然后
Jake: Then...
Lucia: 不能全撒
Lucia: Can't spread them all.
Jake:不能全撒
Jake: Can't spread them all.
Jake:对要保证金融市场事从无
Jake: Right, we have to ensure the financial market remains stable.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 我是这边记得是两点半到3点入场
Katrina: I remember we enter between 2:30 and 3:00.
Katrina: 然后introduction and Q&A是3点到3:40
Katrina: Then the introduction and Q&A is from 3:00 to 3:40.
Katrina: 嗯那这个暖场游戏是啥时候呢
Katrina: So, when is the warm-up game?
Katrina: 就在2点半到3点之间
Katrina: It's between 2:30 and 3:00.
Jake:对 2点半到三点
Jake: Yes, 2:30 to 3:00.
Tasha:暖场是什么游戏
Tasha: What's the warm-up game?
Jake:来的人就来
Jake: People just come.
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Find the coin.
Jake:对找币
Jake: Yes, find the coin.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Find the coin.
Katrina: 然后想玩那个拼图的就玩拼图
Katrina: And if you want to play the puzzle, play the puzzle.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: Okay.
Jake:然后如果拼起来的话
Jake: And if you complete it...
Katrina: 可以奖励
Katrina: You get a reward.
Katrina: 拼不起来的
Katrina: If you can't complete it...
Lucia:拼不起来放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry, you won't complete it.
Alice:要不按照块拼吧
Alice: How about we just do it piece by piece?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
修确：就是你拼到几个
Shure: Like, how many pieces you complete.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 那总共有几个块来着
Shure: So, how many pieces in total?
Jake:大概几十个吧
Jake: Around dozens, I guess.
Alice:好几十个吧
Alice: Quite a lot, right?
Katrina: 他们有个就圆形的拼图很难拼
Katrina: They have a round puzzle that's really hard.
Tasha:三十
Tasha: Thirty.
Jake:你们作为每拼起来的人
Jake: For each person who completes...
Shure: 就是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 每
Shure: Each...
Katrina: 就是所有的动物很不规则
Katrina: All the animals are irregular shapes.
Jake:就就大概点评一下给个稍为
Jake: Just give a brief comment and maybe...
Jake:随便给点钱吧要不就
Jake: Just give some money or something.
Katrina: 反正他们那天拼了一个小时
Katrina: Anyway, they spent an hour on it that day.
Shure: 每拼进去多少个
Shure: For each piece you complete...
Shure: 然后我们给
Shure: We'll give you...
Shure: 就比如说每拼进5个
Shure: For example, every 5 pieces...
Shure: 我可以给你一个
Shure: You get one.
Shure: 你要能拼
Shure: If you can complete...
Tasha:拼5个就给一个币啊
Tasha: You get a coin for every 5 pieces?
Tasha:你这小抠搜
Tasha: You're such a cheapskate.
Tasha:抠搜的
Tasha: So stingy.
Alice:你知道那个有多难吗
Alice: Do you know how hard that is?
Lucia:知道有多难吗
Lucia: Do you know how hard it is?
Alice:我都快拼瞎了
Alice: I'm almost going blind from working so hard.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure: 你我
Shure: You and I...
Jake:哈哈哈一个币很难挣的
Jake: Hahaha, it's really hard to earn a coin.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 你这是破坏市场
Shure: You're destroying the market.
Jake:你知道现在一个
Jake: Do you know now one...
Tasha:你才是
Tasha:你知道现在一个矿业吗
Tasha: Do you know now one mining?
Tasha:真的剥削你知道吗
Tasha: It's really exploitative, you know?
Jake:一个矿业多少钱吗
Jake: Do you know how much one mining is worth?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Lucia: 你说是big矿业吗
Lucia: Are you talking about big mining?
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia:他说一个矿多少钱
Lucia: He said how much one mine is worth.
Lucia:我说是比特币吗
Lucia: I said, is it Bitcoin?
Lucia:哈哈哈这差不多吧
Lucia: Hahaha, that's about right.
Jake:一开始也不值钱对吧
Jake: At first, it wasn't worth much, right?
Alice:我们都快拼瞎了
Alice: We're almost going blind from working so hard.
Lucia:那你真得把咱这上链上链
Lucia: Then you really need to put us on the blockchain.
Lucia:给他注成NFT算了
Lucia: Just turn it into an NFT.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:没关系要不然就按时间吧
Alice: It's okay, otherwise, let's just go by time.
Shure: 阿猫阿猫通他们都在NFT
Shure: Everyone's on NFT, even the cats and dogs.
Alice:他们嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:不管拼成什么样
Alice: No matter how it turns out.
Shure: 元宇宙 我元你家的激发宇宙
Shure: Metaverse, I'll generate a universe for your home.
Alice:能坐上15分钟就给他个两三个之类的
Alice: If you can sit for 15 minutes, give them two or three of those.
Jake:什么呀什么东西
Jake: What? What is it?
Lucia:木子膏呀
Lucia: Mùzǐgāo!
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 你不知道这
Shure: You don't know that?
Lucia:有一首歌
Lucia: There's a song.
Shure: 是的热狗的一首歌叫做NFT
Shure: Yeah, Hotdog has a song called NFT.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:听懂一个词
Jake: I understood one word.
Lucia: 感觉都是哔哔哔
Lucia: Feels like it's all beep beep beep
Lucia:哈哈哈对自带消音效果
Lucia: Hahaha yeah, it's like it comes with its own censoring effect
Shure: 可以听一下这个词
Shure: Can we listen to this word?
Katrina: 那就这样
Katrina: So, that's it
Katrina: 3点哈哈哈
Katrina: 3 o'clock hahaha
Jake:行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay
Katrina: 3点到3:40是他们自我介绍
Katrina: 3:00 to 3:40 is their self-introduction
Katrina: 和我们的知识问答
Katrina: And our Q&A
Katrina: 然后3:40到4:20是我们host part
Katrina: Then from 3:40 to 4:20, it's our host part
Katrina: 就是我们介绍我们每个人的东西
Katrina: Which means we introduce our stuff
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 4:20到5点是他们介绍他们带来的东西
Katrina: From 4:20 to 5:00, they introduce their stuff
Katrina: 拍卖嗯
Katrina: Auction, yeah
Katrina: 然后5点半左右就是订的
Katrina: Then around 5:30, it's the order
Katrina: 然后就是披萨
Katrina: And then it's pizza
Katrina: 然后6点
Katrina: And then at 6:00
Katrina: 6点多的时候就可以开始唱
Katrina: Around 6 o'clock, we can start singing
Katrina: 唱歌什么的
Katrina: Singing and stuff
Katrina: 晚上就指定了
Katrina: It's scheduled in the evening
Katrina: 唱歌好像
Katrina: For singing, I think
Jake:对晚上没啥大吃
Jake: Yeah, there's nothing big to eat in the evening
Katrina: 哦哦我想起来就是那个呃
Katrina: Oh, oh I remember, it's that, uh
Katrina: 4:20 host part结束以后最后压轴的是他们
Katrina: After the host part ends at 4:20, the final act is them
Katrina: 然后就可以尝一下他的甜品嗯
Katrina: And then we can try their desserts, yeah
Jake:啊是我不是
Jake: Ah, is it me?
Jake:这本来就是吗
Jake: Wasn't it always like this?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:嗑完为
Jake: After we're done
Katrina: 早上做来得及吗
Katrina: Is there enough time to do it in the morning?
Shure: 哎不行
Shure: Uh, no
Katrina: 3点才开始嘞
Katrina: It starts at 3 o'clock
Shure: 卫多美哈哈哈哈
Shure: Weidomei hahaha
Lucia: 番茄沙司吗
Lucia: Ketchup?
Shure: 好利来没说
Shure: Holiland didn't say
Shure: 卫多美可能不知道
Shure: Weidomei might not know
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Katrina: 然后那个什么调节
Katrina: Then, adjust that
Shure: 卢锡河
Shure: Lucia River
Katrina: 今天晚上就指定了一个这个活动
Katrina: Tonight, we scheduled this event
Katrina: 唱唱歌然后8点结束
Katrina: Sing a bit, and then it ends at 8 o'clock
Katrina: 差不多6点开
Katrina: We'll start around 6.
Katrina: 65点半的
Katrina: Maybe 6:30.
Katrina: 晚饭的话可能6:15开始吧
Katrina: Dinner might start around 6:15.
Katrina: 6:15-8点唱歌一个多小时
Katrina: Singing from 6:15 to 8 for over an hour.
Katrina: 嗯嗯没了
Katrina: Yeah, that's it.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Sounds about right.
Shure: 行我们批一点
Shure: Okay, let's go with that.
Shure: 不要那么高
Shure: Not too high.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:咱那个barbecue是啥意思
Jake: What's the deal with the barbecue?
Katrina: barbeque还搞吗
Katrina: Are we still doing the barbecue?
Katrina: barbeque那碳昨天剩了半天咋
Katrina: We had half the charcoal left from yesterday.
Jake:现在啥意思
Jake: What's the plan now?
Jake:要不从明天开始烧吧
Jake: How about we start grilling tomorrow?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 烧没了给
Shure: Finish grilling it.
Katrina: 这很难找
Katrina: It's hard to find.
Lucia: 这很难烧
Lucia: It's hard to grill.
Shure: 那个有点太困难了
Shure: That's a bit too difficult.
Jake:哈哈哈东北人
Jake: Hahaha, Northerners.
Shure: 是不是
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是不是咱们昨天自个吃上了吧
Shure: Didn't we eat it ourselves yesterday?
Jake:是吃上了
Jake: Yeah, we did.
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:花了两个小时吃上了
Jake: Spent two hours eating it.
Jake:那如果要搞barbecue的话
Jake: So if we're doing the barbecue,
Katrina: 不是明天又得去采购吗
Katrina: Don't we need to go shopping again tomorrow?
Jake:是买点直接买点串好的之类的
Jake: Yeah, just buy some pre-skewered stuff.
Jake:就美团嘛是吧
Jake: Just order from Meituan, right?
Lucia:要不别烤了
Lucia: Or we can skip grilling.
Shure: 要不直接点熟的
Shure: Or just order cooked ones.
Jake:熟的直接烧
Jake: Cooked ones, then grill them.
Jake:对熟的然后再在烤箱上面温
Jake: Yeah, cooked ones and then heat them in the oven.
Shure: 温着温着
Shure: Heat them up.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Lucia: 因为这个烧起来的时间
Lucia: Because the grilling time
Lucia:可能是三到更无穷所以就太难控制了
Lucia: could be anywhere from three to infinite hours, so it's hard to control.
Katrina: 还有咱那个酒的那个饮料也没了
Katrina: Also, we're out of drink mixers.
Katrina: 我们那个酒的饮料啊
Katrina: Our drink mixers are gone.
Katrina: 维他
Katrina: Vita.
Shure: 酒yes维他
Shure: Alcohol, yes, Vita.
Katrina: 外卖吧
Katrina: Let's order takeout.
Shure: 然后哦
Shure: And then, oh...
Shure: 明天那个dinner time的时候喷个香槟
Shure: Tomorrow during dinner time, let's pop some champagne.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:哦这回给力点哈给力点
Jake: Oh, this time, let's make it great, make it awesome.
Shure: 这这回必须得优雅的
Shure: This time it has to be elegant.
Shure: 这回我就手崩坏了
Shure: My hand might mess it up.
Shure: 我都得把这香槟崩出去
Shure: I might even shoot the champagne everywhere.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 哈哈哈要么就是我手飞出去
Shure: Haha, or my hand might just fly off.
Shure: 要么就是盖飞出去
Shure: Or the cap might fly off.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这吓人
Katrina: That's scary.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: That's it.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Shure: 没了
Shure: That's it.
Shure: 要不就这样
Shure: How about we leave it at that?
Jake:就这样
Jake: Let's leave it at that.
Shure: 那休息
Shure: Then let's rest.
Alice:还有装饰房间的
Alice: And we need to decorate the room.
Jake:装饰房间是
Jake: Decorate the room?
Katrina: 装饰房间
Katrina: Decorate the room.
Katrina: 要给他们看吗
Katrina: Should we show them?
Katrina: 还是就我们自己内部看看
Katrina: Or just keep it to ourselves?
Jake:呃他给他们看
Jake: Uh, let's show them.
Jake:因为不是不是藏东西得
Jake: Because we're not hiding anything.
Tasha: 藏到房间里
Tasha: Hide it in the room.
Jake:合适吗
Jake: Is that suitable?
Shure: 不合适吧
Shure: It's not suitable, right?
Jake:不合适
Jake: Not suitable.
Shure: 哈哈哈你笑什么
Shure: Hahaha, why are you laughing?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 没笑
Katrina: I'm not laughing.
Shure: 你仿佛看到了什么一样
Shure: It’s like you've seen something.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 没看见
Katrina: I didn't see anything.
Shure: 不是你脸为什么那么红
Shure: Why is your face so red then?
Shure: 你看到我什么了吗
Shure: Did you see something about me?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我脸红了吗我没喝
Katrina: Hahaha, am I blushing? I didn't drink.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 那就那个环节设置在哪啊
Katrina: So where do we set that up?
Jake:那个环节
Jake: That part.
Jake:incho吧就在这
Jake: Right here at Incho.
Jake:可能Q a之前就是暖场吧
Jake: Probably just warm-up before Q&A.
Katrina: 就是两点半到三点
Katrina: From 2:30 to 3:00?
Jake:对两点半到三
Jake: Yeah, 2:30 to 3:00.
Jake:三点一开始先暖个场吧
Jake: Start warming up at 3:00.
Jake:大家转一圈
Jake: Everyone mingles.
Jake:然后坐坐到座位上
Jake: Then sit down at your seats.
Katrina: OK对那就
Katrina: Okay, got it.
Jake:就是三点
Jake: So at 3:00.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Got it.
Jake:大家游戏
Jake: Everyone plays a game.
Jake:就是在客厅这边
Jake: Right here in the living room.
Jake:把币给把撒的币给找着
Jake: Look for the scattered coins.
Jake:然后找完之后就开始开始
Jake: After finding them, we'll start.
Jake:然后大家每个人带他们走一圈
Jake: Then everyone takes a tour.
Jake:走一圈之后买东西
Jake: After the tour, buy stuff.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Got it.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 我们是不是
Shure: Should we...
Shure: 杨老板应该做个总体的presentation呢
Shure: Should Jake do an overall presentation?
Jake:做做一个
Jake: Do one.
Jake:做个开场呗
Jake: An opening, right?
Jake:对欢迎各位嘉宾各位领导
Jake: Yes, welcome all the guests and leaders.
Shure: 杨老板得做一个小的小的答辩是吧
Shure: Jake should do a small defense, right?
Shure: 对我们为难为难他
Shure: Yeah, let's challenge him.
Shure: 为什么要这么做
Shure: Why do we need to do this?
Shure: 百度让我这么做的哈哈哈
Shure: Baidu told me to do it, hahaha.
Shure: 这就是我的答辩
Shure: That's my defense.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 我真的挺好答的
Shure: It's really easy to answer.
Lucia:只答不辩
Lucia: Just answer, no defense.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:那就收工
Jake: Let's call it a day.
Jake:收工
Jake: Wrapping up.
Shure: 关卧好
Shure: Close the room properly.